And then, yeah, and then she crossed herself again. I'm like, what is about to happen right now? And then as we're going down the side of this, you know, crater wall, I swear I'm not making this up. I looked over and there was an airplane fuselage just on the hill. Just, you know, they don't all make it. It's a numbers game. Some of them end up on the side, you know. and welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 121 recorded on February 16th 2023 my name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce we finished part five of our five-part interview
然后，是的，然后她又划了十字。我想，接下来到底会发生什么？然后当我们沿着这个，你知道，火山口壁往下走的时候，我发誓我绝对没有编造。我望过去，山坡上居然就有一架飞机的机身。就是，你知道，并不是所有人都能成功着陆的。这是一个概率游戏。其中一些最终会停在山坡上，你知道的。欢迎收看 ADSP 播客第 121 期，录制于 2023 年 2 月 16 日，我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯完成了我们五部分采访的第五部分
with Zach Lane today we get some random stories from Zach and chat about a number of other random topics. Well, we have to get at least – do you have to go anywhere, Zach? We have to get at least one Zach Army story because they're all hilarious. So there's a brief one that I like like from this is when i was at uh c plus is now a few years ago i think it's like right before the the pandemic and at the time um uh which was jason turner's uh podcast i've forgotten the name cpp cast cpp cast yeah so i was sitting there and hanging out with some folks ben dean is one of them ben's a super nice guy and i said somehow we got to
采访对象是扎克·莱恩，今天我们从扎克那里听到了一些随机的故事，并聊了许多其他随机话题。好吧，我们至少得——扎克，你待会儿要去哪儿吗？我们至少得听一个扎克军队的故事，因为它们都太搞笑了。所以有一个简短的故事我挺喜欢的，这是在我去，呃，C++ Now 的几年前，我想大概是在大流行爆发前不久，当时，嗯，呃，那是杰森·特纳的播客，我忘了名字了，CPP Cast，CPP Cast，对。所以当时我和一些人坐在一起闲逛，本·迪恩就是其中之一，本是一个超级好的人，然后我说，不知怎么的，我们开始
talking about that podcast. And I said, yeah, I'm kind of bummed they never asked me to come on the podcast. Like, I don't really actually want to go on the podcast that bad. I just want to be asked. Wait, you were never a guest? No, no, I was never on there. What? And so I said, really, I just want them to ask me so I can say, you know what, I got a lot going on right now. I can't relate. And then Ben turns around to Jason who is right there and he says, Jason, hey, how about having Zach on your podcast?
聊起了那个播客。我说，是的，他们从来没有邀请我上播客，我其实有点失落。其实我并不是真的很想上这个播客。我只是想被邀请。等等，你从来没有当过嘉宾？不，不，我从来没上过。什么？所以我说，真的，我只是想让他们邀请我，这样我就可以说，你知道吗，我最近有很多事情要忙。我没空。然后本转过身对就在那里的杰森说，杰森，嘿，让扎克上你的播客怎么样？
He's like, oh, yeah, Zach, would you like to come on the podcast? I said, you know what? I got a lot going on right now. This is perfect instant gratification of exactly what I want. I'm like, Ben, you need to just, I need to just take you with me everywhere. It's just an instant wish fulfillment. Wow. So wait, is this your first C++? I mean, we're like C++++ podcast. Is this your first C++ podcast? No, you said you were on CPP chat. Yeah, I was on CPP chat, but that was with a whole bunch of people from SG16, the Unicode folks. Unicode is one of the things I work on, not because I wanted
他说，哦，对啊，扎克，你想上这个播客吗？我说，你知道吗？我最近有很多事情要忙。这简直完美地即时满足了我的愿望。我说，本，你只需要，我真该把你带到任何地方去。这简直就是即时愿望实现。哇。等等，这是你的第一个 C++ 吗？我的意思是，我们就像 C++ 播客一样。这是你的第一个 C++ 播客吗？不对，你说过你上过 CPP Chat。对，我上过 CPP Chat，但那是和来自 SG16 的一大群人，也就是 Unicode 的那些人一起。Unicode 是我从事的工作之一，并不是因为我想
to know anything about Unicode. I kind of accidentally- Nobody really wants to know anything about Unicode. I love Unicode. Yeah, exactly. How do you think we get those APL BQN symbols? Let's make it happen. Unicode, baby. Yeah. But we're not fun Unicode people. We're the kind of Unicode people that say, we should have a rule for what can be in an identifier, like a kind of Unicode people that say like, we should have a rule for like what can be in an identifier, like a name of a function or something. And because we need a rule, we're going to go and make the rules make sense. And that means you can't use the shit emoji anymore in your, in your slideware.
了解关于 Unicode 的任何事情。我有点偶然——没有人真的想了解关于 Unicode 的事情。我爱 Unicode。没错，哈哈。你以为我们是怎么弄到那些 APL BQN 符号的？让它发生吧，Unicode，宝贝。是的。但我们可不是那种有趣的 Unicode 人。我们是那种会说“我们应该为标识符中可以包含什么制定一条规则”的 Unicode 人，就像那种会说“我们应该为标识符中可以包含什么制定规则，比如函数名或类似的东西”的 Unicode 人。而且因为我们需要一条规则，所以我们要去让这些规则变得合理。这意味着你再也不能在你的幻灯片里使用便便表情符号了。
And that really, that really upset some people. Some people like really felt the loss of the poo emoji going away. And yeah, sorry guys. So yeah, that group has done some really interesting stuff, but none of it's very fun. I remember seeing a lightning talk.
这真的，真的让一些人很不高兴。有些人真的为便便表情符号的消失感到惋惜。好吧，对不起了各位。所以，是的，那个小组做了一些非常有趣的事情，但其中没有一件是很好玩的。我记得看过一次闪电演讲。
I think it was at Meeting C++ 2019 maybe where someone did a gobbled compiler explorer all in like emoji. Or maybe it was actually – it was during the Meeting C++ quiz at 2019. Yes, it was. And one of the questions was, what does this evaluate to? And it was like, that was pre-pandemic. Like that was like, we were like on the road
我想那大概是在 2019 年的 Meeting C++ 上，当时有人用一堆表情符号做了一个 Compiler Explorer。或者可能实际上——那是在 2019 年 Meeting C++ 的问答环节中。是的，确实如此。其中一个问题是，这段代码会计算出什么结果？那是在大流行之前。就像我们在路上呆了
for like four or six weeks. Yes. You've told that story like six times on this podcast. All right. So I do have an army story for you. We'll take it. All right.
大约四到六个星期。没错。你在这个播客上已经讲过这个故事大约六次了。好吧。那我确实有一个军队的故事讲给你听。我们洗耳恭听。好吧。
So I was trying, I was trying to think of one. Okay. So there was this guy that I was, he was in my platoon. He was in my squad. I knew him pretty well. This guy's name was. Okay. So there was this guy that I was – he was in my platoon. He was in my squad. I knew him pretty well. This guy's name was Machado.
所以我一直在努力想一个。好吧。当时有这么一个人，他在我的排里。他在我的班里。我对他很了解。这家伙的名字叫。好吧。当时有这么一个人，——他在我的排里。他在我的班里。我对他很了解。这家伙的名字叫马查多。
Machado had this habit of asking insane questions, just what-if questions, just to get the conversation going. It's so weird, right? So I was a paratrooper. So when you do a jump, like you're in a plane, you jump out. The people at the beginning of the jump, at the end of the jump, they come out in very different places. So there's – once you hit the ground, you pack up your chute and everything. You go to this place everyone calls the assembly area where you kind of form back up in your units and stuff. And so the assembly area is a thing we refer to all the time.
马查多有个习惯，喜欢问一些疯狂的问题，就是那种“假设”的问题，纯粹是为了挑起对话。太奇怪了，对吧？我曾是一名伞兵。所以当你跳伞时，你在飞机里，然后跳下去。跳伞开始时的人和跳伞结束时的人，他们降落的地方会有很大的不同。所以一旦你着地，你就要打包好你的降落伞等等。你要去一个大家称之为集合区的地方，在那里你们重新按部队编组等等。所以集合区是我们经常提到的一个地方。
People call it the AA or the AA, right? Okay. So Machado says this. He says, all right, you jump, right? And your shit don't open, right? Okay, so then you pull the reserve. shit don't open right okay so then you pull the reserve that don't open right now what do you do you sprout wings and now you can fly do you go to the assembly area or you just fly away i was like wait what i was like wait wait wait wait
大家称之为 AA 或者 AA，对吧？好吧，马查多是这么说的。他说，好吧，你跳伞了，对吧？然后你的降落伞没有打开，对吧？好吧，那你拉了备用伞。伞还是没打开，对吧？那现在你该怎么办？你长出了翅膀，现在你能飞了，你是去集合区还是直接飞走？我说，等等，什么？我说，等等，等等，等等，
what does the first part have to do with the second part i don't understand this you said like what if i sprouted wings where would i go and then somehow you tied this into jumping out of an airplane and going to the assembly like i don't understand like i have so many questions about this question this is the most insane question anyone's ever asked oh machado he's full of questions like that some that are really probably not podcast appropriate, but bizarre, bizarre scenarios this guy would come up with. Oh, man. That guy was nuts. Well, it's the answer.
第一部分和第二部分有什么关系？我不明白你在说什么。你说“如果我长出了翅膀，我会去哪儿”，然后不知怎么的，你把这个和从飞机上跳下来去集合区联系在一起——我不明白，我对这个问题有太多的疑问。这是我听过的任何人问过的最疯狂的问题。哦，马查多，他脑子里全是这种问题，有些可能真的不太适合在播客里播，但这家伙总能想出一些稀奇古怪、匪夷所思的场景。天哪。这家伙疯了。答案是什么？
What's the answer? I mean, I would probably fly to the assembly area and say, I got a lot going on right now. I'm going to fly away. We got to meet up at a conference it's been two when was the last time we saw each other Zach I think it was
答案是什么？我的话，大概会飞到集合区然后说，我最近有很多事情要忙。我要飞走了。我们得在会议上见个面，距离我们上次见面已经两年了，扎克，上一次我们见面是什么时候？我想那是
2019 like four years are you coming out well I wait did you come to the C++ Now in 2019 might have been 2018 no
2019 年，大约四年了。你要来吗？好吧，我等等——你2019年去过 C++ Now 吗？可能是 2018 年，不对，
the first conference I ever went to was the C++ Now 2019 okay and then there was a few for that year and then
我参加的第一场会议是 2019 年的 C++ Now，好吧，那年之后去过几次，然后
I met you at a couple of committee meetings as well. Yeah. But then, yeah, since then, yeah, it's coming up in May. I'm definitely going to be there.
我在几次委员会会议上也遇到过你。是的。不过，自那以后，对，马上就要到五月份了。我一定会去的。
If you want to come to aspirants, it's a, I was invited, but, uh, I can't, I've got, um,
如果你想来参加，这是一个，我被邀请了，但是，呃，我不能去，我有
two races that bookend that weekend. I basically, I'm not sure unless if I skip those races in some, at some point in the future. Are you, did you submit Bryce? Are you going to see us now? So I submitted,
两场比赛正好夹在那周末的两端。基本上，除非我在未来某个时候放弃那些比赛，否则我不确定。布莱斯，你提交了吗？你要去 C++ Now 吗？所以我提交了，
I don't know if I'm going to go because conference travels, not like work sponsored conference travels, not going to happen. So that's pay out of pocket, which I might do. But I also, I may have a, a work thing I have to do that weekend, that week. not like work sponsored conference travel is not going to happen. So that's pay out of pocket, which I might do. But I also, I may have a work thing I have to do that weekend, that week, which is in Italy. And like, I love, I love all the C++ people, but you know, if I have to pick between you,
我不知道我会不会去，因为会议差旅，不是那种公司赞助的会议差旅，是不可能有的。所以那是自掏腰包，我可能会去。但我也，我可能那个周末，那周有个工作上的事情要处理。不是那种公司赞助的会议差旅，是不可能有的。所以那是自掏腰包，我可能会去。但我也，我可能那个周末，那周有个工作上的事情要处理，在意大利。而且，我爱，我爱所有的 C++ 伙伴，但你知道，如果让我选择你们，
y'all and hanging out in the Amalfi Coast, I'm going to go with the Amalfi Coast. Do you have any other conferences lined up, Zach? No. So since I go to committee meetings really faithfully these days, I basically have limited myself to just that one conference. I just go to C++ now. And I got to say, I went to CppCon the first two years and it wasn't, I think, as mature a conference as it is now. I think the program is better now than it was the first two years. Right. So there's that. But I really felt like when I went the first two years, like after having gone to C++ now, it's such a singular experience.
大家还是在阿马尔菲海岸闲逛，我肯定选阿马尔菲海岸。扎克，你还安排了其他会议吗？没有。因为现在我非常忠实地参加委员会会议，所以我基本上把范围限制在那一个会议上。我只去 C++ Now。我得说，我前两年去了 CppCon，我觉得它当时可能没有现在这么成熟。我认为现在的节目比前两年要好。对吧？就是这样。但我真的觉得我前两年去的时候，在去过 C++ Now 之后，那是一种非常独特的体验。
Like everyone's in this small town with nowhere to go, nothing to do, but like to do the conference. That really makes a really tight group. But then also like the caliber of the presentations, like they aren't all great, but the ones that you see there that are great are like, wow, this like changes a lot of things for me. You know, they're really influential. Whereas I didn't really feel like I saw anything like that at the first two years of CPPCon. So, again, I think it's a better conference. I think I would have more sort of like great experiences in terms of the presentations themselves. But the fact that it's so like sort of distributed – I should say distributed.
每个人都在这个小镇里，无处可去，无所事事，除了参加会议。这确实形成了一个非常紧密的群体。而且演讲的水平也是，虽然不是每个都很好，但在那里看到那些精彩的演讲时，你会觉得，哇，这让我改变了很多事情。你知道，它们真的很有影响力。而我在前两年参加 CppCon 时并没有这种感觉。所以，再说一次，我认为它是一个更好的会议。就演讲本身而言，我会有更多很棒的体验。但由于它太分散了——我应该说分散。
So big is what I'm trying to say. It's a completely different experience. Yeah, it's hard to run into people and just have a chance, a discussion with folks. So I really think like I've kind of been spoiled by this one conference I really like so much. If I go to another one, I'm like always comparing it to that one. So I think I won't get as much out of other conferences. So that's part of it. Yeah. It's very hard to replicate, especially the venue that they have. And it's an Aspen. Like it's, I don't think I've ever gone to a conference anywhere else where the running has been so phenomenal. And like,
我想说的是它太大了。这是一种完全不同的体验。是的，很难遇到人并与大家进行随意的讨论。所以我真的觉得我被我非常喜欢的那一个会议给惯坏了。如果我去另一个会议，我总是会拿它和那个会议作比较。所以我从其他会议中收获不会那么多。所以这也是一部分原因。是的，这很难复制，尤其是他们的场地。而且是在阿斯本。就像，我想我从来没有去过其他任何地方的跑步体验能如此 phénoménal（非凡）——
and like you're technically like, I don't treat it like that, but you're at altitude. And so like, if you are going for runs for a week, then you go back down to sea level or wherever you're at. And you're like, Holy smokes. I mean, it feels great. What happened? And like, I remember actually the first couple of times where I went for runs up there, I was just like, why am I so tired? Am I not getting enough sleep? Or like, cause, cause they are long days. And like, you know, you're, you're basically, you wake up watching talks, talking in between every single talk, dinner, lunches, like it's very, very, you know, you're, you're basically, you wake up watching talks, talking in between every single talk, dinner, lunches, like it's very, very, you know, and sometimes you'd be up till 2am, 3am in the morning, like, you know, chatting about technical stuff or whatever, just, you know, meeting with folks.
而且从技术上讲，——我不会这样对待它，但你在高海拔地区。所以如果你在那里跑步一个星期，然后回到海平面或你所在的任何地方。你会觉得，天哪。我的意思是，感觉太棒了。怎么回事？而且，我还记得实际上前几次我在那儿跑步时，我只是在想，为什么我这么累？我是不是睡眠不足？或者，因为，因为那里的日子很长。而且，你知道，你，基本上，你醒来就是看演讲，每个演讲之间都在聊天，晚餐，午餐，——这非常非常，你知道，你，基本上，你醒来就是看演讲，每个演讲之间都在聊天，晚餐，午餐，——这非常非常，你知道，有时你甚至会熬夜到凌晨两点、三点，你知道，聊技术方面的事情或者其他什么，只是，你知道，和大家见面。
And, uh, but I'm like, usually even if I'm tired, like I don't feel this bad. And then I realized, oh yeah, like there's less oxygen up here. Like, uh, it impacts your ability to feel, feel good. And it's just so beautiful. Um, yeah, it's a great spot, but yeah, the altitude really gets to you. So early on in the, in the conference, like I think right before I had my first kid or something, you know, I used, I used to lift weights pretty, pretty, um, um, faithfully. And I did it like all the time. I didn't want to miss like a whole week. Right. So I go into the weight room there. And, you know, they didn't have free weights. I was just on the little bench press machine.
而且，呃，但我觉得通常即使我很累，我也不会感觉这么糟糕。然后我意识到，哦，对了，这里的氧气比较少。像，呃，这会影响你感觉良好的能力。而且这里太美了。呃，这是一个好地方，但是，呃，高海拔确实让人吃不消。所以在会议早期，——我想大概是在我第一个孩子出生前不久之类的时候，你知道，我以前经常非常，非常，呃，认真地举重。而且我一直都在做。我不想错过整整一个星期。对吧。所以我走进了那里的健身房。
I just put on like my warm-up weight and I went and just didn't move my hands. I'm like, okay, let me take a plate off. And I still couldn't move it. And then finally I got down to like the bar and like a little bit more. And then I could barely move it all the way up and I got so tired. I was like, okay, maybe I'll skip this week. Yeah. I don't know if I'm going to be able to do this.
而且，你知道，他们没有自由重量器械。我只是在那个小卧推机上。我刚换上热身重量，然后去推，结果手根本没动。我想，好吧，让我卸下一片杠铃片。我还是推不动。最后我只剩下一根杠杆和一点点重量。然后我勉强把它推到顶，我累极了。我想，好吧，也许我这周不练了。是的。我不知道我能不能做到这一点。
Yeah. It definitely impacts. One year, we used to have this fellow. I think his name was Ed who would come every year. But then there was one year where the altitude just got to him. And I think he collapsed or something. And he was just like, I can't come back. It's just this is too – the air is too thin here.
是的，它确实有影响。有一年，我们曾有这么一位老兄。我想他叫埃德，每年都会来。但有一年，高海拔实在让他吃不消了。我想他晕倒了还是怎么的。然后他说，我再也不能来了。这实在是——这里的空气太稀薄了。
Yeah. And that's the thing. I've been told that altitude sickness is kind of funny. Like people will be fine for a while and then they'll get it. I'm talking about repeated trips. If you're there and you acclimate that's one thing but like people who have done things at altitude for a number of years they'll feel like they're comfortable with it and they'll go back again and they'll have problems and i think that's what happened to ed because ed was like a regular he'd been to several
是的，就是这样。有人告诉我，高原反应挺奇妙的。人们一开始会没事，然后就会出现反应。我说的是多次往返。如果你在那里并适应了，那是另一回事。但对于那些在高原上做过好几年事情的人来说，他们会觉得自己已经习惯了，然后再去就会出问题。我想这就是埃德遇到的情况，因为埃德是个常客，他去过好几次
of them and then he couldn't go after that it's always like hit or miss for me like some years like i don't feel it at all some you and i think it depends on whether you drive up from denver or you fly right in like if i fly right into aspen, like, yeah, I'm going to, I'm going to feel it. Yeah. Yeah. This is why Tony, Tony Van Eerd, who's a local Ontarioan who lives out in Kitchener, I believe. Hope I got that right. He was saying that, you know, for, we've got C++ North, which is held downtown Toronto,
会议，在那之后他就去不了了。对我来说这总是碰运气——有些年份我一点感觉都没有，有些年份——而且我认为这取决于你是从丹佛开车上来还是直接坐飞机来。如果我直接飞到阿斯本，是的，我肯定会有感觉。是的。这就是为什么托尼·范·埃尔德（Tony Van Eerd），一个住在基奇纳的安大略本地人，我相信我没记错的话。希望我没说错。他说，你看，对于，我们有 C++ North，在多伦多市中心举行，
but we could try and replicate the the c++ now kind of experience and call it like c++ muskoka which would be probably easier to get to because it would just be like a car ride plus a flight to toronto whereas most people i mean i don't know if it's half and half some people fly into aspen i. I remember landing in Aspen, though, and thinking, like, you know, of the times – I know statistically speaking, flying is the safest. But just, like, you're flying through mountains and, like, finding this little thing, and I'm like – So the flights into Aspen, I always feel super safe on those flights because the pilots need a special rating to fly into, like, a handful of mountain airports in the in the US, and that's one of them. And so the pilots that you get on those flights are usually
但我们可以尝试复制 C++ Now 那种体验，把它叫做 C++ 马斯科卡（C++ Muskoka），那样可能更容易到达，因为只需要开车加上飞往多伦多的航班，而大多数人，我的意思是，我不知道是不是一半对一半，有些人飞到阿斯本。不过我记得在阿斯本着陆时，我想，你知道，在那些时候——我知道从统计学上讲，飞行是最安全的。但只是，就像，你飞越群山，然后寻找这个小小的落脚点，我在想——所以飞往阿斯本的航班，我总是觉得超级安全，因为飞行员需要特殊的执照才能在美国少数几个山区机场降落，而这就是其中之一。所以你在这些航班上遇到的飞行员通常
like, they're like hot shots, like former Navy pilots. Yeah, they tend to know their stuff. I landed in Tegucigalpa Airport, which is in an extinct volcano. That's where the city is.
就像是王牌飞行员，前海军飞行员。是的，他们往往很有一套。我在特古西加尔巴机场降落过，那个机场在一个死火山里。城市就在那里。
So where do you put the airport? On the edge of the city, right? You don't put it downtown, right? So then when you're landing, you don't want the takeoff to be up against the crater wall. So when you land, you're coming like down the crater wall and then you pull up at the last second and you land there. And I remember I was near the front of the plane and I could see the woman who had been our flight attendant in our section sitting, you know,
那你把机场放在哪儿？在城市边缘，对吧？你不会把它放在市中心，对吧？所以在你降落时，你可不想起飞时撞上火山口壁。所以当你降落时，你要顺着火山口壁往下飞，然后在最后一秒拉起，然后降落在那儿。我记得我坐在飞机前部附近，我能看到我们那个区域的空姐坐在那里，
facing us. So she's like, you know, by the aisle side seat, the other flight attendants, my kids here, but, and she's sitting there and she's like mumbling to herself and like her eyes are closed. And I'm like, what is happening? And then she crosses herself. Yeah, I was going to say that she do a little. Yeah, and then she crossed herself again. I'm like, what is about to happen right now? And then as we're going down the side of this, you know, crater wall, I swear I'm not making this up. I looked over and there was an airplane fuselage just on the hill. Just, you know, they don't all make it.
面向我们。所以她就像，你知道的，坐在靠走道的座位上，另一个空姐，我的孩子们在这儿，但，她坐在那里，嘴里嘟囔着什么，眼睛闭着。我在想，发生什么事了？然后她划了十字。对，我正要说她做了一个小小的。是的，然后她又划了十字。我想，接下来到底会发生什么？然后当我们沿着这个，你知道，火山口壁往下走的时候，我发誓我绝对没有编造。我望过去，山坡上就有一架飞机的机身。就是，你知道，并不是所有人都能成功着陆的。
It's a numbers game. Some of them end up on the side, you know, they don't all make it. It's a numbers game. Some of them end up on the side, you know. And when we landed, she got on the PA and she said, let's all thank the pilot. Everyone applauded. I felt like there would have been a standing ovation if we weren't buckled in. Like, it was insane. I was like, how dangerous was that? Like, they didn't tell me before I got on the plane.
这是一个概率游戏。其中一些最终会停在山坡上，你知道的，并不是所有人都能成功着陆的。这是一个概率游戏。其中一些最终会停在山坡上，你知道的。当我们着陆时，她通过机上广播说，让我们一起感谢机长。所有人都鼓掌了。如果不是系着安全带，我感觉大家都要起立鼓掌了。太疯狂了。我在想，这有多危险啊？他们在我上飞机前可没告诉我。
They just told me, like, as we're about to land. And they didn't even tell me without crossing themselves. That was the communication. Yeah, it was like c post post now 2013 or 2014 but there was a blizzard as as there often isn't that early in may and um i i was in denver waiting for the flight to to um to go and it was like unclear like a lot of the flights after mine had been canceled already it this was the last one that was going to go if any of them were going to go and then um this guy in like a bombardier jacket like not like typical airline pilot uniform this guy was out of regulations he uh he walks um up from the jet bridge into the area and he swipes the microphone from the gate agent.
他们只是在我们要着陆的时候才告诉我。而且他们告诉我的时候还划了十字。这就是他们的交流方式。是的，那就像是 2013 或 2014 年的 C++ Now，当时有一场暴风雪，正如五月初那样经常发生的那样，呃，我在丹佛等待飞往，呃，飞往那里的航班，当时情况很不确定——我之后的很多航班都已经取消了。如果还有任何航班能飞，这将是最后一班。然后，呃，这个穿着庞巴迪夹克的人——不是那种典型的航空公司飞行员制服，这家伙不符合着陆规范，他，呃，从登机桥走到大厅里，一把抢过了登机口工作人员的麦克风。
And he's like, well, hello, folks. My name is Captain whatever. And he's like, well, they've given us enough fuel that we could divert to Los Angeles if we needed to. So we're all going to get on this plane and we're going to fly on over to Aspen. And I'm going to see if I feel like we can land. And if we can, we'll do that. If not, we're going to go somewhere else. And he just said it so confidently that I was like, you know, I'm going to get on the plane with this man.
他说，嗯，各位好。我是某某机长。然后他说，嗯，他们给我们加了足够的燃料，如果需要的话我们可以改飞洛杉矶。所以我们都要上这架飞机，然后飞往阿斯本。我要看看我觉得我们能不能降落。如果可以，我们就这么做；如果不可以，我们就去其他地方。他语气是如此自信，以至于我觉得，你知道的，我要跟这个人上飞机。
Like he seems nervous. And it was the smoothest landing I've ever had into the Aspen airport. In the Aspen airport landing, there's sort of like one valley that they fly you through. And then you have to make a pretty sharp turn in that valley to come into the approach to the airport. Yeah. And as we're landing, there's like zero visibility. But it was the smoothest landing I've ever had in that airport. And when everybody landed, we all gave that man a round of applause.
他看起来并不紧张。那是我在阿斯本机场经历过最平稳的一次着陆。在阿斯本机场降落时，基本上要穿过一个山谷。然后你必须在那个山谷里做一个相当急的转弯，才能进入机场的进近航线。是的。在我们降落时，能见度几乎为零。但那是我在那个机场经历过最平稳的一次着陆。当所有人着陆后，我们都给那个人鼓掌喝彩。
Yeah. That landing could be kind of rough there yeah i don't i don't know what's happening but yeah even even now when i'm just on regular flights i i have a certain amount of anxiety even though like it's like i studied statistics in university and i know the statistics of flying but there's just something like even in a car i have anxiety it's just like when you're in this you know, but there's just something like even in a car, I have anxiety. It's just like when you're in this, you know, metal box, there's just, you're sort of, you're at the whims of whatever happens, right? Like, it's not like, all right, we go down, I'm going to make sure I got my, my, you know, my, my position I've practiced and I'll be okay. And I'll get, I'll get out the little floppy thing first.
是的，那里的着陆可能有点粗暴，是的，我不知道怎么回事，但，是的，即使到现在，当我只是坐普通的航班时，我也会有一定的焦虑，尽管，这就像我在大学里学过统计学，我知道飞行的统计数据，但总有那么一回事，甚至在车里我也会有焦虑，就像当你在这个，你知道的，金属盒子里，你只是，你任由发生的一切摆布，对吧？就像，这不是那种，好吧，我们要坠机了，我要确保我做好准备，我练习过那个姿势，我会没事的。我会先把那个小充气滑梯弄出来。
It's like, nah, you know, all the other things that they tell you about, like, make sure you put the gas. It's like, that's, i'm pretty sure just a distraction and like if the plane goes down into a side of a mountain you know like all these over the last what decade or however many flights have disappeared like you don't hear about the one or two people that survived you know the the flight that went it's it's it's kind of it um which anyways i think those those uh those tanks are full of nitrous oxide or something just something just they just come down they just they just knock you out unfortunately in the in the crash landing that was successful we did lose five people because there was too much too much
就像是，不，你知道，他们告诉你那些其他的事情，比如确保你把气放掉。这就像，我敢肯定那只是个干扰，而且如果飞机撞向山坡，你知道的，就像过去这十年左右或不管多少消失的航班一样——你根本不会听到那仅有的一个或两个幸存者（的故事），你知道的，坠毁的航班，这有点，它，不管怎样，我认为那些，那些油箱里装满了笑气或者别的什么东西，就是有些东西，它们直接坠毁，它们只是，它们只是把你撞晕了，不幸的是，在那个成功的紧急迫降中，我们确实失去了五个人，因为有太多，太多
mix so so piece of trivia do you know why commercial airplanes don't have parachutes for all the passengers uh no i assume because it's cost prohibitive, but I don't know. It's actually not cost. Part of it is weight, but most planes are flying at between 30,000 and 40,000 feet. And you can't jump from that height without an oxygen mask. You'll pass out. Yeah, that's a good point. And so one, the plane would have to get a lot lower um two for most of the sorts of problems that you'd have on a plane the amount of time that
混合了。所以，来个冷知识，你知道为什么商业飞机不为所有乘客配备降落伞吗？呃，不知道，我猜是因为成本太高，但我不知道。其实不是成本问题。部分原因是重量，但大多数飞机飞行高度在 30,000 到 40,000 英尺之间。没有氧气面罩，你无法从那个高度跳伞。你会昏迷的。是的，很有道理。所以第一，飞机必须飞得低得多；
it would take to get 250 people like to jump off the plane like it'd be crashed by then and three most people who are flying on a plane haven't been trained to use a parachute and so it wouldn't like even help you and so i always just thought it was like a cost thing or a weight thing, but it turns out it's mostly just like, no, it really wouldn't help you out that much. Well, also, when I used to jump in the Army, we were usually jumping in the C-130s, which is a prop plane, right? They aren't going that fast. And then when we did jump out of the bigger planes with the jet engines,
第二，对于你在飞机上可能遇到的绝大多数问题来说，让 250 个人跳下飞机所需的时间——到那时候飞机早就坠毁了；第三，大多数坐飞机的人都没有受过使用降落伞的训练，所以这甚至对你没有帮助。所以我一直以为这是成本问题或重量问题，但事实证明，主要还是因为，不，它真的对你没有太大帮助。好吧，还有，我以前在军队跳伞时，我们通常是从 C-130 运输机上跳伞，那是一种螺旋桨飞机，对吧？它们飞得不是那么快。然后当我们从带有喷气发动机的大型飞机上跳下来时，
they would slow down a lot, right? Because you can't jump out and then get slammed against the side of the door. You know, that's not going to work, right? It's not going to end well. It's not going to end well. And some of the ones that had the big jet engines, they actually had this kind of flap with holes in it that would come out in front of the doorway that would break the wind.
它们的飞行速度会慢很多，对吧？因为你不能跳出去然后猛烈撞击机门侧面。你知道，那行不通，对吧？不会有好结果的。不会有好结果的。而且有些带有巨大喷气发动机的飞机，它们实际上在门前有一个带孔的襟翼，会在舱门前展开以阻挡气流。
So you could actually, as you're going out, you keep a good body position until you actually hit the stream of air going past right so there's all kinds of technical things oh this is actually really funny like i saw a video they were they were they're trying to get there's these uh c5 globe masters these gigantic planes they can i think they could put two abrams tanks in them and and fly them like halfway around the world they're gigantic the inside of it you feel like an aircraft hangar. You can't believe how big it is inside these planes. And they were trying to figure out how to jump paratroopers out of them. They had all kinds of problems with it.
这样当你跳出去时，你可以保持一个良好的身体姿势，直到你真正撞击流经的气流——所以有各种各样的技术问题。哦，这其实真的很有趣，我看到过一个视频，他们试图让——这些 C-5“银河”运输机，那些巨大的飞机，我想它们可以装下两辆艾布拉姆斯坦克并把它们运送到半个世界之外，它们太巨大了。里面感觉就像一个飞机库。你简直不敢相信这些飞机里面有多大。他们一直在琢磨怎么让伞兵从里面跳伞。他们遇到了各种各样的问题。
So these wings, they have those canards, the big things that stick up on the end of the wing, the little canards, I don't know what it's called. So it turns out those make like a little vortex around the back of the wings, a little swirly pattern. And I saw this video where they were like they were like they were flight testing you know because when you when you jump
所以这些机翼，它们有那些小翼帆，就是机翼末端翘起的大东西，那些小翼帆，我不知道它叫什么。事实证明，那些东西会在机翼后面产生一个小涡流，一种小小的旋转模式。我看到过这样一个视频，他们正在进行飞行测试，你知道，因为当你在军队里跳伞时，
in the military they have like a static line so when you fall out you could be a sack of bricks you're still gonna the shoot's still gonna open up right so they literally put like weights uh and and and put like uh uh like kind of weighted dummies and put chutes on them and then just threw them out right just see what would happen and and i saw this video of this plane and you see all these little will look like little people coming out and then they're floating down nice and gentle like you would expect in a parachute and then they hit that huge swirling vortex of air and they went upside down landed in the chute and then just went straight and hit the ground oh no i don't want to jump out of that
他们有一根牵引绳，所以当你掉出去时，就算你是个砖袋，降落伞还是会打开，对吧？所以他们真的放了一些重量，然后放了类似加重的人体模型，给它们装上降落伞，然后就把它们扔出去了，为了看看会发生什么。我看到这个飞机的视频，你看到所有这些看起来像小人一样的东西出来，然后它们像你对降落伞的期望那样平稳地往下飘，接着它们撞上了那个巨大的旋转气流涡流，然后就倒过来，撞在伞上，接着直接笔直地撞向地面。哦，不，我可不想从那上面跳下去。
no no me gust that's not for me that's not for me so uh so my my girlfriend has actually been skydiving which is a thing that i think i would i i would not do unless somebody pushed me out of the plane. I might sign up for it, but somebody would have to shove me out of the plane. But yeah, it's like that's... How many times did you say you jumped out of a plane? I did like 35 times. You've not done it since you've been in the Army? No, no. I mean, there's a lot of things. Like, you know, I used to love camping.
不，不，我可不干，那不适合我，那不适合我。所以，呃，我女朋友其实去玩过跳伞，这是我觉得我绝不会做的一件事，除非有人把我从飞机上推出去。我可能会报名，但必须有人把我推出去。不过，是的，就像那是——你说你从飞机上跳下来多少次？我跳了大约 35 次。自从你加入军队后你就没再跳过了吗？没有，没有。我的意思是，有很多事情。就像，你知道的，我以前很喜欢露营。
And then when I got paid to camp outside for two months a year, I was like, I never want to camp again. You know, there's certain things like it kind of ruins certain things for you. So when I first started jumping, it was so exciting. Oh, my God, it was so much fun. And then I hit my head on something. I don't even know what happened because I just woke up on the ground and didn't know how I got there. So I hit my head so hard that I lost a whole day. And after that, it was like, okay, this real now this is not this is not super fun anymore so um you know like my sort of like um
然后当我一年有两个月拿薪水在外面露营时，我想，我再也不想露营了。你知道，有些事情，它会毁掉你对某些事情的兴趣。所以当我刚开始跳伞时，太令人兴奋了。哦，天哪，太好玩了。然后我的头撞到了什么东西。我甚至不知道发生了什么，因为我醒来时已经躺在地上，甚至不知道自己是怎么到那里的。我把头撞得太厉害以至于失忆了一整天。在那之后，我就觉得，好吧，这太真实了，这不再，这不再那么有趣了。所以，呃，你知道的，我的那种，呃，
the the honeymoon period was over at that point i'm not that interested anymore yeah yeah yeah that that seems to me like a wise like i i bet it's thrilling but like people human man was not meant to yeah well i mean the very first time i did it i remember i was looking out the window i happened to be sitting right in front of the door and they open up the door and i'm looking out and i see all these little tiny trees that look like you know like when someone makes a model of like a development and there's these little little these little fake trees that's what it looked like i was like it doesn't even look real and you're jumping from about 1200 feet you're not jumping jumping very high and um uh you know you you do one of these jumps and and it doesn't feel real but i the first time i went i was like this is
蜜月期在那时就结束了。我不再那么感兴趣了。是的，是的，那在我看来是一个明智的决定——我打赌这很刺激，但人类本来就不是为了——好吧，我记得我第一次做这件事时，我正看着窗户，我刚好坐在门的正前方，他们打开门，我向外看，我看到所有这些微小的树木，看起来就像，你知道的，就像有人制作了一个开发区的模型，里面有这些小小的小假树，那就是它的样子。我想，这看起来甚至不真实。而且你跳伞的高度大约是 1200 英尺，你跳得并不高。呃，
how i die this is i'm definitely dying right now this is like it's so terrifying i was just like blind with panic but somehow i made myself go out and then then when the shoot opened and you went from this deafening noise of all the wind and it was silent and I was alive and it was thrilling. I was like, I'm hooked this. I want to do this over and over again. It was so much fun. And then,
你知道，你做了其中一次跳伞，这感觉不真实，但我第一次去的时候，我在想，这就是我死的方式，这绝对是我现在就要死了，这太可怕了，我当时被恐慌弄得盲目，但我不知怎么的还是让自己跳了出去。然后当降落伞打开，风的震耳欲聋的声音消失了，周围变得一片寂静，而我还活着，这太刺激了。我想，我迷上这个了。我想一遍又一遍地做这个。太好玩了。然后，
like I said, it got really real later. Yeah. Oh man. I have absolutely zero desire. Like, I don't know if it makes me like an unfun person, but like skydiving,
就像我说的，后来它变得非常真实。噢，天哪。我完全没有欲望。就像，不知道这是否显得我很无趣，但是跳伞、
bungee jump, like bungee jumping just seems like, that's just how you like cause yourself like the rest of your life, neck problems. And like, you know, oh yeah. Whipped your neck. And like, I guess it was a cool Instagram reel, but, uh, I just, oh man, like that. Right. Who's next in the whiplash machine? It just seems like asking for trouble. Yeah. I mean, yeah. Instagram's good enough for that. I'll just watch people doing the reels. Yeah. All you got to do is get really good at Photoshopping your face on someone else's head.
蹦极，就像蹦极看起来就像，那只是你给自己余生带来颈部问题的方式。而且，你知道，哦，是的。扭伤了你的颈部。而且，我想这是一个很酷的 Instagram 短视频，但是，呃，我只是，哦，天哪，就像那样。没错。谁是下一个在挥鞭样损伤机器里的人？这看起来简直是自找麻烦。是的。我的意思是，是的。Instagram 对此来说已经足够好了。我只要看别人拍的短视频就行了。是的，你只需要非常擅长把你的脸 P 到别人的头上。
Yeah. You don't even need to get good at it now. Like all the drama with deep fakes and stuff going on. This is by far, I think, our longest recording. I can't remember how long we recorded with Chandler. It's been great, though. Yeah. Yeah, it's great.
是的。你现在甚至不需要 P 得多好。就像所有关于深度伪造之类的闹剧一样。这绝对是我认为我们录制时间最长的一次。我不记得我们和钱德勒录了多久了。不过真的很棒。是的。是的，太棒了。
Just glad to be on. At this point, we stopped our local recordings because we were done recording the episode. However, we continued to record on Zoom unintentionally as the Zoom meeting was continuing. And we actually ended up chatting for about 30 or 40 minutes after the end of the recording, some of which might be interesting for the listeners. So if you are interested, the rest of the podcast is an unedited behind the scenes, just chatting between Bryce, Zach, and myself.
很高兴能上节目。此时，我们结束了本地录音，因为我们已经完成了本集内容的录制。然而，由于 Zoom 会议仍在继续，我们无意中继续在 Zoom 上录制。事实上，我们在录音结束后又闲聊了大约 30 或 40 分钟，其中一些内容对听众来说可能会很有趣。所以如果你感兴趣的话，播客的剩余部分是未经剪辑的幕后花絮，只是布莱斯、扎克和我之间的闲聊。
Every once in a while, we skip ahead, which will be indicated by a record scratch because that's the boring stuff. But hopefully you enjoy this behind the scenes with Zach and Bryce. So I gotta say the only thing, what? Oh, it's exporting. Yeah. The only thing, the only tip to improve your podcast that I could possibly give you is that at the end of every podcast, it's just Connor's voice saying like, all right, bye, click.
每隔一段时间，我们会跳过一些内容，这会用黑胶唱片的刮擦声来表示，因为那些都是无聊的内容。但希望你喜欢这段有扎克和布莱斯的幕后花絮。所以，我得说唯一的，什么？哦，正在导出。是的。唯一的，我能给你的改进播客的唯一建议是，在每个播客的结束时，只有康纳的声音说“好了，拜拜，点击”。
It is so abrupt. I'm like that was it oh shit it's over you gotta have an outro bro so abrupt well the thing is is that like i designed my podcast because i listened to like 60 podcasts or something like just today i've already listened to i don't know probably three hours of content because i listen at 2.3 times. And there's like certain things that just are really big pet peeves. And like, I never listened to the outros as soon as there's outros. Although I will say mine is aggressively like, it's like a three second recording of thanks for listening.
太突然了。我想，这就结束了？哦，操，结束了。你得有一个片尾曲啊，兄弟。太突然了。嗯，问题是，我设计我的播客是因为我听了大约 60 个播客左右，仅仅今天我已经听了，我不知道，大概三个小时的内容，因为我是以 2.3 倍速听的。而且有些事情简直是超级大忌。就像，只要有片尾曲，我就从来不听片尾曲。虽然我得承认我的片尾曲非常激进，就像一个三秒钟的录音：“感谢收听。
Hope you enjoyed. Have a great day. Bye. All right. One, one fun fact before I, before I let you guys go, you know, who else is a paratrooper, former paratrooper,
希望你喜欢。祝你有美好的一天。再见。”好吧，一个，在放你们走之前的一个有趣的事实，你知道谁也是伞兵，前伞兵吗？
Andre Alexander rescue. Yes, I did know this. Is that crazy? I know this because a couple weeks after, um, or maybe like a month or two after Andre starts working at NVIDIA, um, we, uh, we get on like our regular one-on-one and we're chatting. And then at the end, he's like, hey, like before you go, you know, there's a chance I may have to like, I may get called up to like go back to the Romanian army for a few months.
安德烈·亚历山大·雷斯库。是的，我知道这个。是不是很疯狂？我知道这个是因为安德烈开始在英伟达工作几周后，或者大概是一两个月后，我们，呃，我们进行了例行的个人一对一会议并聊了聊。然后在最后，他说，嘿，在你走之前，你知道的，我可能会有机会，我可能会被召回罗马尼亚军队几个月。
You think NVIDIA will be cool with that? And I'm like, wait, what? He's like, yeah, I'm kind of an officer in the in the reserves maybe need me to go teach the kids things and i could get out of it but i want to go do it that's really interesting yeah the only reason i know that is because it actually says that in his little um you know the the like uh bio blurb thingy that you put in your book sorry and it said that in his um uh at the end of his uh advanced or modern c++ design yeah yeah but when i saw that i was like that's crazy i think it's amazing that he's still on like the reserve list there yeah yeah i mean i think he's even older than me i'm like i'm not
你觉得英伟达会介意吗？我说，等等，什么？他说，是的，我差不多是预备役军官，可能需要我去教孩子们一些东西，我可以推脱掉，但我想去。这真的很有趣。是的，我之所以知道这一点，其实是因为它写在他的小，呃，你知道的，你放在书里的那种个人简介小短文里，抱歉，他的，呃，在他的《高级或现代 C++ 设计》的末尾写了。是的，是的，但当我看到那个时，我就想，这太疯狂了。我觉得他居然还在那里的预备役名单上，这太神奇了。是的，是的，我的意思是，我觉得他甚至比我还老。我想，我可不
gonna do that shit yeah yeah yeah in fact you know my stress dreams are not like i'm in class with no pants on instead i have to run again my stress dreams are back in the army for some reason like there's been a war and i've been called up and i have to run and i'm like oh this sucks so do you have enough time to edit this like how exactly is this gonna work oh that's the thing is you think that like and i i i can't remember i think i did mention this when um cpp cast had shut down last may like almost a year ago is that uh like i was saying how much i was gonna miss the podcast and love it and like they put way more work into um i mean like like literally Zach, you know how you got on this, like Bryce just sent you an email and then like two days later, you know, and then you hit like, uh, I remember, uh, they had all these settings.
要干那种破事。是的，是的。事实上，你知道我的压力梦不是“我上课时没穿裤子”，而是“我又得去跑步了”。我的压力梦不知怎么的是回到了军队，就像爆发了一场战争，我被征召了，我必须跑步，我想，哦，这太糟了。那么，你有足够的时间来编辑这个吗？这到底是怎么运作的？哦，这就是关键，你以为——而且我，我记不清了，我想我确实提到过，当 CPP Cast 去年五月停播时——差不多一年前，我说过我会有多想念这个播客并有多爱它，他们为此投入了大量的工作——我的意思是，像扎克，你知道你是怎么上这个节目的，布莱斯只是给你发了一封电子邮件，然后大约两天后，你知道的，然后你点击，呃，我记得，他们有各种设置。
We don't have settings. I don't, I don't switch thing. Like I think Bryce records on two speakers and I record on mono. Like, I don't really care. And my goal is to like have the whole thing, show notes, website updates, edits, and like outro intro all done in like an hour. Oh, wow. And that's why, that's why I try and keep it to like 30 minutes because like every 30 minutes you add is going to double the amount of time. Yeah. And I, like, I get comments all the time about Bryce's audio is too low. And, you know, we got a blah, blah, blah. But that's the thing is Bryce talks like this and he goes like this and he talks like this and he talks like this.
我们没有设置。我，我不会切换东西。就像我认为布莱斯用双声道录音，而我用单声道录音。我其实不在乎。我的目标是让整期节目、节目文稿、网站更新、剪辑，以及片尾和片头都在一个小时内搞定。哦，哇。这就是为什么，这也是为什么我尽量把它控制在 30 分钟左右，因为你每增加 30 分钟，就会使时间翻倍。是的。而且，我总是收到评论说布莱斯的音频太小声了。而且，你知道，我们有巴拉巴拉。但问题是布莱斯说话是这样的，他会这样，然后他会这样说话，他还会这样说话。
You know, they don't they don't make a normalization algorithm for what I do. And there are times where like you can do this stuff where like you amp everything down to a certain level and then re amplify it. But like, even still, you know so most of the times I just listened to yours. I had a fascinating conversation with Richard Powell, who works at Apple and does audio stuff there, like talking about like, like this quite like normalization and like the, like the loudness of things. It was really, I was fascinated. I, so I had a, I had a long conversation with Richard Powell, Richard Powell about their smart speaker and everything he was describing was stuff I did in Navy Sonar.
你知道，他们没有为我所做的事情制作归一化算法。有时你可以做这样的事情，比如把所有东西放大到一个特定的水平，然后重新放大。但即便如此，你知道，大多数时候我只是听你的。我和在苹果工作并负责音频业务的理查德·鲍威尔进行了一次迷人的对话，谈论了类似这种归一化以及声音响度的问题。真的让我很着迷。我跟理查德·鲍威尔进行了长谈，关于他们的智能音箱，他描述的一切都是我在海军声纳里做过的事情。
Like it's all the same like approaches and algorithms and like worrying about which bounce paths of this taking to get back to you. It's really fascinating. Somewhere at Apple, I'm sure there's some engineer who like used to be like a Navy like Sonar guy. Now his job is to make sure the home pod can like listen to you yeah so um yeah we did we also didn't talk about unicode stuff i mean you know there's yeah we didn't talk really about any of your libraries i wanted to bring up the uh i'll be the first uh person to come on 18 times yeah yeah well i was thinking too i meant to mention this at the end is that sean's probably listening being like, why the hell haven't these guys? Cause it was half of the idea was that like, I was always telling Sean, it's like, man, like, you know how popular, like if you did a podcast, like imparting your wisdom to the world and he's like, no, no, no, I don't have time for that.
就像所有的方法和算法都是一样的，还要担心它为了回到你身边采取了哪些反射路径。这真的很着迷。在苹果的某个地方，我确信有某个工程师以前就像是海军声纳方面的人。现在他的工作是确保HomePod能够听懂你说话。所以，是的，我们也没有谈论Unicode的事情，我的意思是，你知道，我们真的没有谈论你的任何库。我想提一下，我是第一个来18次的人。好吧，我也在想，我本打算在最后提到这一点，肖恩可能在听，心里会想，这些家伙到底为什么还没提？因为有一半的想法是，我总是告诉肖恩，就像，伙计，你知道有多受欢迎吗，如果你做一个播客，把你的智慧传授给世界，而他却说，不，不，不，我没有时间。
And I was like, no, man, like your stories are so amazing. Like, so honestly, this is the problem with C++ instruction. Really? It is like that all the cool kids are like, I don't want to do that. I'm so busy, right? And then like, you know, people used to write books and stuff because there was money in it. But now there's no money in it. So people don't write books anymore. Yeah. And so like now it's like you have to have like, you know, there's a few labors of love.
然后我说，不，伙计，你的故事太棒了。说实话，这就是C++教学的问题所在。真的吗？就像所有酷炫的孩子都说，我不想做那个。我很忙，对吧？然后，你知道，人们过去常常写书之类的内容，因为里面有钱。但现在里面没钱了。所以人们不再写书了。是的。所以现在就像你必须有，你知道，有一些出于热爱的付出。
Like CPP reference is a great example of that. Like the people who do that do a great job with it. But also you have people like Richard Smith will come in and edit the stuff about the language. So you have some heavy hitters editing their stuff. But usually, if it's in terms of tutorial-level documentation, there's no such thing for C++. And the reason it doesn't exist is because no one's going to make a name for themselves doing that. Just like no one's going to make a name for themselves figuring out package Just like no one's going to make a name for themselves figuring out package management. No one's going to be known as the package management guru.
像CPP reference就是一个很好的例子。做这件事的人把它做得很好。但同时你也有像理查德·斯密斯这样的人进来编辑关于语言的内容。所以你有一些重量级人物在编辑他们的内容。但通常，如果是教程级别的文档，C++并没有这种东西。它之所以不存在，是因为没有人会通过做这个来让自己出名。就像没有人会通过弄清楚包管理来让自己出名一样。没有人会被称为包管理大师。
That's just not something people want to know for themselves. One of the problems is that there's not enough money. Most languages have a foundation that's better funded, and then the foundation has some people on staff, and then they do stuff like that. Dust Foundation is a great example. The C++ Foundation has paid people people but as far as i know that that list is one person long they paid eric niebler for a while to finish the range of stuff and i don't think they've ever done it with anyone else but yeah look at what came out of that right yeah what came out of that was incredible like we should do more of that but you know
这根本不是人们想让自己出名的事情。问题之一就是资金不足。大多数语言都有一个资金更充足的基金会，然后基金会里有一些员工，他们就会做这样的事情。D语言基金会就是一个很好的例子。C++基金会有带薪员工，但据我所知，那个名单上只有一个人。他们付钱给埃里克·尼布勒一段时间来完成范围相关的内容，我不认为他们对其他人做过类似的事情。但是，看，从那里面产出了什么，对吧？是的，产出的东西太不可思议了——我们应该多做那样的事情，但你知道
what's interesting is i heard um i heard a podcast with j, uh, Jason's cousin and not just in terms of like, yeah. And, and I was, I was hearing this too, cause it's sort of a rhetoric is why, why Russ became so popular where it has a lot of the same things that Haskell has, but Haskell didn't. And what JT did, like they had this, um, committee, like they have a bunch of committees language api blah blah blah but they had one for like um community or like you know i can't remember what it was but it was like community outreach or something and they did this survey where they realized that like the number one thing people struggled with was like uh like fighting with the compiler and so they created this whole initiative to basically do like compiler driven development,
有趣的是，我听说，我听过一个播客，里面有J，杰森的表弟，不仅是在……是的。而且，我当时也在听这个，因为这有点像一种言论，为什么Rust变得如此受欢迎，它拥有很多Haskell拥有的东西，而Haskell却没有。而JT所做的事情，就像他们有这个，委员会，就像他们有一堆语言API的委员会等等，但他们有一个专门针对社区的，或者，你知道，我不记得它具体是什么了，但它就像社区拓展之类的，他们做了一项调查，发现人们苦恼的第一件事就是和编译器斗争，于是他们创建了整个倡议，基本上是为了实现类似编译器驱动的开发，
focus so much attention on not just the errors, but like the errors that beginners run into that like might not actually be things that like experienced developers are running into, but it's like these low level, like, or very, like the first things you're going to learn and like put that, those tips in the compiler. So that basically like, you don't even need to go to Stack Overflow. You hit some wall, and then the compiler's immediately... And hearing them talk about that was like, maybe that's what Rust... People talk about the evangelism strike force
把如此多的注意力不仅集中在错误上，而且集中在初学者遇到的那些经验丰富的开发者可能不会遇到的错误上，但它就像这些底层的，或者非常初学时最先要学习的东西，并把这些提示放到编译器中。基本上，你甚至不需要去Stack Overflow。你遇到了某种墙壁，然后编译器立刻……听到他们谈论这个，就像，也许这就是Rust……人们谈论布道突击队
and how they're propaganda, blah, blah, blah. But I think Rust really figured something out in designing the experience that new people have with the language to be incredibly like a soft landing, even when you're struck, like five years ago, you used to hear that Rust is such a hard language to learn and blah, blah, blah. And, you know, move by default and all these things and coming from Python. And now like, you don't hear that as much anymore. Like it's, it's this language that some people like learning as a first language. And I just like, I think there's so much to learn from like, not just what Russ has done
以及他们的宣传等等。但我认为Rust在设计新手对这门语言的体验方面确实找到了诀窍，让他们感觉像是一个极其平稳的着陆，即使你被难住了。比如五年前，你经常听到Rust是一门多么难学的语言等等，默认移动以及所有这些来自Python的东西。而现在，你听到的没那么多了。它已经变成了一门有些人喜欢作为第一门语言来学习的语言。我只是觉得，不仅仅要向Rust作为一门语言所做的事情学习，还要向他们作为一个社区所做的事情学习，这里面有太多东西值得借鉴。
as a language, but what they've done as a community. Yeah, that's really what's most appealing to me. So, you know, whenever I write parsers, I try to make a parser that when there's an error, it tells you which production rule it thought it was going to have. And that's plain English. And it puts a carrot under it, just like the clan diagnost diagnostics and it quotes the line and all that kind of stuff and i find that when you use most people's parsers they don't do anything like that and it makes it so unergonomic and i really feel like you know i've spent my entire career being good at writing libraries
是的，这确实对我吸引力最大。所以，你知道，每当我编写解析器时，我都试图制作一个解析器，当出现错误时，它会告诉你它以为会遇到哪个产生式规则。而且那是用平白易懂的英文。它在下面放一个脱字符，就像Clang诊断信息那样，它会引用那行代码以及所有这些东西。我发现当你使用大多数人的解析器时，它们根本不这样做，这让它变得非常不符合人体工学。我真的觉得，你知道，我整个职业生涯都在擅长编写库，
getting better and better writing libraries and one of the things i've discovered and this is part of this is due to eric neibler in fact who i remember writing him writing on the boost list one point like the story for error recovery is part of your library that's part of the quality metrics for your library like if you if you report errors and the errors are like this much template instantiation stack page after page after page and then it's like you know it gives you something you don't even understand how it relates to your code then that's a problem so you should basically be like static asserting those things ahead of time or like Sveenation kick in or something like this. And I feel like the committee has, the committee gives zero about that. There's just no buy-in for that approach. And I think it's so damn important, but we have at this point,
不断改进编写库的能力。我发现的事情之一——其实部分原因要归功于埃里克·尼布勒，我记得他在Boost列表上写过一件事，关于错误恢复的方案其实是你库的一部分，那是你库的质量指标的一部分。如果你报告错误，而错误就像是这样一页接一页的模板实例化堆栈页面，然后它给你的东西你甚至都不知道它和你的代码有什么关系，那这就是个问题。所以你基本上应该提前对这些东西进行静态断言，或者让SFINAE机制介入之类的。我觉得委员会，委员会对这一点完全不在乎。这种方法根本没有得到认可。我觉得这该死的重要，但我们现在有了一门
a very expert friendly language. And so that's the orientation. Yeah. Yeah yeah we are the exact example i mean i hope jessica kerr brings it up she's keynoting at cpp north but she has this amazing slide and talk or slide from a talk that's like commit like different communities across programming languages and like some programming languages are a single step function like down here is the beginners then there's a huge wall and then there's like the people at the top and like getting up there is extremely hard. And then she shows this other slide of other communities referring to like Elixir and Ruby, where it's like a step function.
对专家非常友好的语言。所以这就是它的导向。是的，是的，我们就是确切的例子，我的意思是，我希望杰西卡·科尔能提出这一点，她在CPP North上做主旨演讲，但她有一个非常棒的幻灯片和演讲，或者说演讲中的一张幻灯片，讲的是编程语言中的不同社区，有些编程语言是单一阶跃函数——这里是初学者，然后是一堵巨大的墙，接着是顶尖的人，爬上去极其困难。然后她展示了另一张幻灯片，指的是Elixir和Ruby之类的其他社区，那就像是阶跃函数。
And it's like, not only is it one step function, there's like another step function on the other side that like, there's multiple paths. The people that are one step above you are always happy to teach and writing blogs. You don't get shamed for like not being an expert. Like I remember when I was talking to Andre and he actually put this out in a lightning talk, which I, he said that you shouldn't be giving a talk unless if like you're giving, you're talking about 10% of what you know. So like you should be an expert and like what you're presenting on is a fraction of your knowledge so that like you have all your extra knowledge to answer the questions. Make sure you have the competence.
而且，不仅是一个阶跃函数，另一边还有另一个阶跃函数，有多种路径。比你高一级的人总是很高兴教你并写博客。你不会因为不是专家而感到羞耻。我记得我和安德烈交谈时，他实际上在闪电演讲中提出了这一点，他说，除非你谈论的是你所知内容的10%，否则你不应该做演讲。所以你应该是个专家，并且你展示的内容只是你知识的一小部分，这样你就有所有额外的知识来回答问题。确保你有能力。
No competence, no talk. I'm not kidding. Very serious. Study related work. Be able to defend in a court of law every single word you say. Be able to talk to someone whose life is that topic. All right?
没有能力，就别演讲。我不是在开玩笑。研究相关工作。要在法庭上能够捍卫你所说的每一个字。能够与那些以该主题为生的人对话。好吗？
Who sleeps, eats and showers and everything is that one topic that you touch in, in passing. Okay. So you should be able to have a conversation with them. What you teach should be only a small fraction of what you know, never teach everything. You can't teach everything. You know, you teach a little, what you know, and then the questions are going to take you to the other 80% of things that you know. I could, I vehemently disagree with that so much. Cause when I started giving my talks, I was talking about like 120% of what I knew, like 20% of the stuff I was talking about, I wasn't even an expert on.
他们睡觉、吃饭、洗澡，一切都是你顺便触及的那一个主题。好吧。所以你应该能够与他们对话。你教的东西应该只是你所知的一小部分，永远不要教所有东西。你无法教完所有东西。你知道，你教一点你知道的，然后问题会把你带到你所知道的其他80%的事情上。我强烈反对这种说法。因为当我开始做演讲时，我讲的是我所知内容的120%左右，我讲的东西里有20%甚至都不是专家。
And like the people in the room would be pointing things out and like, I would give answers, but like looking back on it, like I hadn't even fully crystallized my actual thoughts about like what I was answering. And I just think, I think it's, it's such, such a terrible thing to like, tell your community, make sure that you go learn 10 times as much knowledge as you're going to present so that like, you can represent yourself well, where I'm just like, no, like everyone at every level should be making content because there's someone that is like a poor version at like level five of like 20 levels
房间里的人会指出一些问题，然后我会给出答案，但回想起来，对于我所回答的问题，我甚至还没有完全梳理出自己真正的想法。我只是觉得，告诉你的社区“确保你去学习十倍于你将要展示的知识，以便你能很好地代表自己”是一件非常糟糕的事情，而我的看法是，不，每个层级的所有人都应该创作内容，因为在20个级别中处于第5级的一个糟糕版本，正是处于第4级的人所需要的。
is going to be what the person at level four needs. And the person at level 20, isn't going to be able to speak to the person at level four. And sure. Maybe the person at level five messes up a couple of things, but like, anyways, I just like, I have very strong feelings about like, you know, it's, it's kind of like gatekeeping. Like, you know, if, if I had heard that early on, if it hadn't been for Bryce, basically Bryce like twisted my arm because my goal was to give my talk at a meetup and then get it accepted at CPPCon. He saw the talk, which was my goal. I was like, I need either John Cobb or Bryce to see my talk. And then like, that'll help me get accepted.
而处于第20级的人将无法与处于第4级的人对话。当然。也许处于第5级的人会搞砸一些事情，不管怎样，我只是觉得，我对这种事情有着强烈的感受，这有点像守门人心理。你知道，如果我早期听到过这个，如果不是布莱斯，基本上是布莱斯扭转了我的胳膊，因为我的目标是在一个聚会上做我的演讲，然后让它被CPPCon接受。他看到了那个演讲，那是我的目标。当时我想，我需要约翰·科布或布莱斯看到我的演讲。然后那会帮助我被接受。
And then Bryce was like, you have to present this at C++ Now. And I had been listening to the podcast and I was like, uh, I know what C++ Now is. It's a conference for experts. Like, I'm not even, I don't even think I would be like, I would fit in as an attendee, let alone a speaker. Like this is a fluffy talk that like, sure touches on some stuff that I think is important, but like compared to Louis Dion's like template metaprogramming parts one and two, I'm like, I don't fit in.
然后布莱斯说，你必须在C++ Now上展示这个。我一直在听播客，当时我想，呃，我知道C++ Now是什么。这是一个专家的会议。我甚至不认为我会像一个与会者那样融入其中，更不用说作为演讲者了。这就像是一个轻量级的演讲，确实触及了一些我认为重要的事情，但与路易·迪昂的第一部分和第二部分模板元编程相比，我觉得我格格不入。
And, um, and like, that was the feedback as well. Like at C++ now, all my feedback was like, no. And then I think it was basically because like Bryce was on the committee that like he kind of pushed my talk through. Anyways, the point being is like- That is true. I'm sure there's like a handful of people that like would fit in a circle that includes the three of us like very well.
而且，这也是收到的反馈。在C++ Now上，我收到的所有反馈都是否定意见。然后我想基本上是因为布莱斯在委员会里，他才把我的演讲推通过了。无论如何，重点是——那是真的。我确信有一小部分人会非常适合一个包含我们三个人的圈子。
And they'd fit right in, but they're just like terrified of getting up on stage because of the reputation that C++ has, that it's just like. Well, one of the things I always want us to do at the conference, and honestly, it's just because I cannot get up early in the morning. I just, it kills me.
他们会完美融入，但他们只是因为C++的名声而害怕走上舞台，因为它的名声就是……好吧，我一直希望我们在会议上做的事情之一，老实说，只是因为我早上起不来。这太要命了。
And me and Tony Van Eerd are always in the bar until four in the morning talking about something, right? And so like what I want to do the first day of that conference, and I think every conference should do this. I think your conference should do this. The first day, one of the things you should say to the orientation crowd, right? Hey, if it's the first time you're at the conference, here's some ground rules. Ground rule number one, if you see a group of people that's
我和托尼·范·埃尔德总是待在酒吧直到凌晨四点讨论某些事情，对吧？所以我想在会议的第一天做的事情，我认为每个会议都应该这样做。我认为你的会议也应该这样做。第一天，你应该对迎新人群说的一件事是，对吧？嘿，如果你是第一次来参加会议，这里有一些基本规则。基本规则一，如果你看到有一群人
going to lunch, you're part of the group of people. Just go get into the group and just go with them to lunch. Don't ask. Don't make it awkward. Just go with them to lunch. If it turns out that they're doing something specific and you're not welcome, it will come up. Right. But just make the going into fault that I'm just part of the crowd and just doing that, you become part of the crowd. And the thing is that like people aren't going to invite you to come with them, but they also aren't going to be bummed that you're there. Right. If you're brand new and they don't know you, you know what I mean? Like people, people can be like more immediately part of the, part of the crowd, a part of the, the, the, uh, the community. Um, if they just sort of like do a lot of things that only work at conferences, like just insinuating yourself
要去吃午饭，你就是那群人的一部分。直接加入那个群体，和他们一起去吃午饭。不要问。不要搞得尴尬。直接和他们一起去。如果事实证明他们在做一些具体的事情而你不受欢迎，那就会提出来。对吧。但要把默认行为设定为我就是人群的一部分，只需这样做，你就会成为人群的一部分。问题在于，人们不会邀请你和他们一起去，但他们也不会因为你在场而感到扫兴。对吧？如果你是个全新的人，他们不认识你，你知道我的意思吗？如果人们只是做许多只在会议上才管用的事情，比如硬把自己
into lunch plans. Right. Um, and, and, and they don't, they don't realize that that's not an insinuation that that's not a, you know, that's hard. That's hard advice to, for like new people. Cause I remember at C++ now it was so easy. Cause I had lit, I'd seen like 200 talks at that point. And it was like, you run into Marshall and I'm like, Oh my God, I've seen every single one of your talks. My favorite one was this one where you were talking about the algorithms and blah, blah, blah. And then he's like, Oh really? And then you find out that his wife's from Canada. And anyway, it's so easy. But like when I was at PLBI, I still was fine going around there.
塞进午饭计划中，他们就能更直接地成为人群的一部分，成为群体、社区的一部分。而且，他们并没有意识到这不是一种硬塞，这不是一个……对于新人们来说，这很难。这是一个很难接受的建议。因为我记得在C++ Now上这太容易了。因为那时我已经看过大约200场演讲了。就像你遇到马歇尔，我会说，哦天哪，我看过你的每一场演讲。我最喜欢的一场是你谈论算法的那场等等。然后他说，哦真的吗？然后你发现他妻子来自加拿大。无论如何，这太容易了。但当我在PLBI时，我在那里四处走动还是挺自在的。
Like I ran into Doug Greger and stuff. But there's definitely like circles where people are talking about stuff that's just like way over my head, you know, about like dependently typed, you know, Agda, you know, or the new extensions to some textbook or paper. And I'm just like, I can sort of walk into that circle and like nod my head, but it is like, it is very intimidating, even for someone that's like, I'm pretty comfortable around people like to go and like self it's yeah. It's, it's very, uh, so this is the thing, like I, I, that same thing happened to me
就像我遇到了道格·格雷格等人。但绝对有些圈子，人们谈论的事情完全超出我的理解能力，比如依赖类型（你知道的，Agda），或者某个教科书或论文的新扩展。我只能勉强走进那个圈子，点点头，但即使对于一个对周围人挺自在的人来说，这也是非常令人生畏的，去……是的。这非常……所以这就是情况，我，我也有过同样的经历
when I was at, um, uh, at, uh, C++ now the very first year. Like I was at a table with like Doug Greger, Dave Abraham, Sean Parent, Howard Hennant, and a couple of other like heavy hitters. And it was me who had been writing code for that 24 months. Right. And I'm just like, I'm just like, you know, I'm just eating and watching. And I'm like, this is amazing. I don't have anything to contribute, but this is amazing. Right. And so I think that you can, even if you're, even if that's your situation, that you can learn a lot from just being a fly on the wall in those conversations. And lots of times you will have things to add and you won't realize it until you get there. So I think that's fine. But I remember like the first couple of years I was in C++ now,
当我在，嗯，在C++ Now的第一年。就像我和道格·格雷格、戴夫·亚伯拉罕、肖恩·帕伦特、霍华德·汉尼特以及其他几个重量级人物坐在一张桌子旁。当时是我，一个写了24个月代码的人。对吧。我当时就像，我只是在吃东西和观察，我想，这太棒了。我没有什么可贡献的，但这太棒了。对吧。所以我认为，你可以，即使那是你的处境，通过在那些对话中做一只墙头草，你也能学到很多东西。很多时候，你会发现自己有话要说，直到你到了那里才意识到。所以我认为这很好。但我记得在我去C++ Now的前几年，
I was a little bit lonely because I didn't really know anybody. And I was like a little too bashful to go insinuate myself into someone else's lunch plans or whatever. So, but, but I think that there's, there's nothing wrong with doing that. And I think that people embrace it when you do it. And the fact that people don't know that when they first attend, that's, that's the thing I'm trying to overcome. Yeah. I think that would be nice. Yeah. Anyway, it is true. I, I, I really got to run, unfortunately. Okay.
我有点孤独，因为我真的谁也不认识。我有点太害羞了，不敢把自己硬塞进别人的午饭计划或别的什么。所以，但是，我认为这样做没有什么错，而且当你这样做时，人们会欣然接受。人们在第一次参加时并不知道这一点，这就是我试图克服的事情。是的，我觉得那样会很好。是的。不管怎样，确实如此，不幸的是，我真的得走了。好吧。
We are at the three hour mark. Yeah. It's been great though. Thank you so much for coming on Zach thanks for coming on zach well and we will we'll have to have you back because i feel like we didn't even talk about like half of the stuff like we didn't talk about cadence which i meant to bring that up as well because it came up in chip wars cadence synopsis and one other company anyways but we got we got boost libraries we got austin to talk about barbecue. We got Cadence to talk about. Until next time. Sounds good. See you guys later. Have a good one. Bye. As always,
我们已经到了三个小时大关。是的。不过真的很棒。非常感谢你来，扎克，谢谢你来，扎克。我们得让你再来，因为我觉得我们甚至没有谈论一半的事情——我们没有谈论Cadence，我本来也打算提这个，因为它在《芯片战争》、Cadence、新思科技和另一家公司中被提及。无论如何，我们有Boost库，我们有奥斯汀谈论烧烤。我们有Cadence要谈。下次见。听起来不错。待会儿见，伙计们。祝你们过得愉快。再见。一如既往，
you can find links for any of the stuff that we talked about in today's episode in the show notes, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion for any comments and questions you might have. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在节目说明中找到今天节目中讨论的任何内容的链接，以及用于任何评论和问题的GitHub讨论链接。谢谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。